مقام
محمود
مقامن صلى الله عليه
وسلم
خدمه اللهب
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسم شفاي صلى الله عليه
وسلم come
‏this is the
best this is the best gi this is best
thing علس
‏of love for other people and for dun
and for the cars and computers and apple
ipads and ipods and you name it all of
that stuff and then
leave the b of
hearts it is defin
unfair especially for the believers i'm
not talking about talking about
believers it is really unfair why why
you would not have a heart of some
الله سبحانه
وتالى محد صلى الله عليه
وسلم res
[Silence]
‏was over the
time there
time
was فضي
صلس الحد رب
العك الله خير
‏beau سب
وتال
foc
قران الله سبحانه
وتالى from سوره الفاتحه
سوره
الناس الله سبحانه وتعالى س ان
قران يا ايها النبي انا ارسلناك شاهدا
ومبشرا
ونذيرا وداعيا الى
الله باذنه وسراجا منيرا
الله سبحانه
وتعالى م ب محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم سراج
منير الامام
البصيري
سز
ايه
يا
محمد بشر
وليس
كالبشر محمد صل
عليهل
not
الله محمد يهس
جبريل عليه
السلام الله سبحانه
وتعالى قران الشيخ جزا الله
خير سوره
الكهف قل انما انا بشر
مثلكم يوحى اليه
يوحى
اليه انما الهكم اله
واحد محمد
بشر وليس
كالبشر بل هو
ياقوته والناس
كالحجر
الله الامام البصير رحمه الله
محمد صل علس
s
diam him
sim
diamond سبحان
الله
yes refle the
‏sister thank you
so thank you for coming thank you for
adv us
for محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم كيف نفهم
حضره النبي عليه الصلاه
والسلام ان الله
وملائكته يصلون على
النبي
يا ايها الذين
امنوا صلوا عليه وسلموا
تسليما اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد عدد ما في
علم
الله وعدد ما
يكون وعدد ما قد
كان وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم تسليما كثيرا
كثيرا اللهم صل على سيدنا
محمد صلاه تنجينا بها من الاهوال والافات
وتقضي لنا بها جميع
الحاجات
وتقربنا اليك اعلى
الدرجات والمقامات
انك حبيب قريب مجيب
الدعوات اللهم صل على سيد نا محمد طب
القلوب
ودوائها وعافيه الابدان
وشفائها ونور الابصار
وضيائها وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم تسليما كثيرا
كثيرا اللهم هب لنا من ازواجنا
وذرياتنا قره
اعين واجعلنا
للمتقين
اماما اللهم انا نسالك حبك وحب من احبك
وحب عمل يقربنا الى
حبك اللهم واجعل لنا نصيب في دعاء
الاولياء
والصالحين برحمه منك يا ارحم الراحمين
واجعلنا هاديين مهديين
يا ذا الجلال
والاكرام سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الفاتحه
[Silence]
جزك الله خير